you know in csgo no matter how far
behind you are no matter how bad the
round is looking nothing tilts the enemy
team off the face of the earth better
than a good ninja defuse I'm calling for
the score eSports and whether you're
sneaking behind enemy lines for that
last second defuse or going for that
ballsy last-ditch smoke ninja I feel
like I could watch these plays all day
so let's do just that and sneak into it
with the top 10 ninja defuses in csgo
kicking off our list at number 10 is a
cheeky play from Dupree who hides on
nukes BC before sneaking into enemy
smoke for a play that left ldl-c
rethinking the meaning of life seeing
that one person in involve me then that
says everything almost gonna be
positives right in the face of you're
free and he goes for the instant yes
offensive that is the play of the paper
today no one is gonna top that that is
for the sickest things I have ever seen
at number 9 we have one of the first one
v5 ninja defuses in csgo after disposing
of for CLG players it seemed like an
easy round win for energy but tarik had
other ideas Justin and it is just tarik
up and holding out in the Z connector
inch defuse
oh my you might have been right oh no
way no way dude no please I'm done dude
like my sanity is literally gone coming
in at number eight is a play from happy
who just says screw it as he goes in for
a gutsy defuse in the smoke right next
to Chris Jay leading to an unlikely
round win for envious able to go ahead
and open up with to all pecans to step
up massively here and happy in this book
he's gonna go bold in a few sorry
there's no way you got away with it
happy what the hell is that this man is
a ninja I think that might be the best
at refusal to see has balls of steel our
number seven spot goes to config up
twelve four against fnatic in the
quarterfinals of epicenter Moscow the
Dane was looking to add some salt to the
wound as he sneaks behind enemy lines to
pull off a clutch for the Aged it should
be a short-lived attempt here from
config it's almost like just back off
and try and save something from this
round carry it over into the next one
because you really aren't gonna be able
to get in here and get the defuse
waiting there I guess if they were all
charging out he's really trying to sneak
past them right here is there enough
time all they spot him out smoke is
gonna be going up flashbang as well he's
inside it can they stop him two seconds
left carving he's going for the ninja
why is it always on the a bomb side of
this map and hard to take stealing all
of fanatics dreams at number six we've
got Jack C in the finals of Adria
Masters season two down 12 seven two by
nipa Lane a nexus we're looking for
anything to get them back in the game
Jack C delivered exactly that with this
slick 1v5 ninja to start an overtime
comeback will
he's letting them pass oh my god no way
no no no no it's happening what it's
he's won he's won the rounds how is this
happened I'm so till is I don't believe
this
this is going on reddit hundred percent
ten seconds I was like Jack see what
you're doing you need to save this all
but I'm just I'm just not a smart man as
he is our next ninja defuse comes from
pentas Tamsin who plays a game of cat
and mouse before pouncing from the
perfect opportunity for a sick one
before ninja defuse to win the round
don't do that
coming in at number four is a 200 IQ
play from devil faced with a 1 V 3 he
Jukes out the members of faze clan with
this unbelievable clutch that saw him
fake an OP save before coming back for a
last-second DPS that we're looking to
save you now
should be there we go
hope he goes or is he he does have a kid
he he does have a kid I want to repeat
he does have a kid and he is he's got
the round anything else going on anymore
this is the weirdest game is the earth
everything positive they lost the round
who's done he's saving me up yep
then goes down slower yeah they've left
the bomb site they've gone up they've
the paper books a ferret that are there
and it's fully defusing with AK it saved
an orb one route sneaking in at number
three is key RB at Dreamhack Malmo after
losing four teammates Kirby was looking
for the hero play as he hidden
construction on infernos be site to pull
off an incredible 1v5 ninja that would
tilt envious off the face of the earth
hey that's opened things up
he's gonna try this he's not sure they
care if he's trying it look he's going
he's actually gonna try and do this he
gets the shot oh my god do it he does
have told him oh god bring he's got it
one versus five get to kill it and the
full defuse no Jillian you set up for it
from the very beginning
can people a qubit just we're saying
it's never gonna happen again that's
gonna 2mv off the planet lay of the
tournament so far I would say
unbelievable scene taking the runner-up
spot on our list is the Polish legend
himself at IEM katowice 2016 in a round
that seemed impossible to win for virtus
Pro snacks turned it all around with
this ninja defuse in a 1v5 situation
against faze clan all connected was
completely lost by that point you'll
Neal was still up in tears was still up
for they hadn't zero vision zero tangles
held so he just goes up in the ticket
booth you there you haven't got what two
or three players coming through and wait
what is this no are you serious right
now play a phase entry Oh
[Music]
serious I've never seen that happen in
three years of crossing I've never seen
that happen not like that not a
professional game and certainly not at a
game of this match
capping off our list at number one is
none other than crimps who shows us he
is an actual ninja as he evades five TSM
players for a ninja defuse you won't
forget using two plus players and a lot
of rounds here and it's costing to pay
off in the late stages here for TSM but
Crim's
[Music]
I don't know what to say SiC is still on
the sights
[Music]
than that is this gonna happen happen as
well
Crim's that is truly disgusting there
and look at him listen to them they're
having the time of their lives over
there oh my god that is so brief lookit
I can't imagine how scent this must be
fuming that it'll be cool identity view
well guys that's our list of the top ten
ninja defuses and if you didn't agree
with it and you want to go in the
comment section and flame us well just
know that I'll be there to defuse the
situation thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]